head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
clay Travis tweeted MSNBC historian says
if you vote for Republicans your kids
will be murdered and democracy will die
ladies and gentlemen without further Ado
and a historian 50 years from now if
historians are allowed to ride in this
country and if there are still free
publishing houses in a free press which
I'm not certain of but if that is true a
historian will say what was at stake
tonight and this week was the fact
whether we will be a democracy in the
future whether our children will be
arrested and conceivably killed we're on
the edge of a brutal authoritarian
system it might be a week away like and
he's going he's this is what happens
they watch MSNBC and this guy says if
the Republicans win they're going to
arrest your children and kill them like
they actually think in their minds the
cop is going to be like
you know Trump's orders walk into your
house take your seven-year-old in cuffs
and then bring him to a firing squad
what are they what are they imagining
happens in this kind of riding the back
of the Trump bad narrative man the whole
Biden Administration and momentum is
based on look how bad Trump was it's so
annoying and now they're now they're
still saying it they've extrapolated it
to Trump's voter base right and how bad
bad bad they are how bad they are it's
just Nazi propaganda man that's what
Hitler did to the Communists with the
reichstag fire it's just this full false
flag nonsense about creating a boogie
man that's what I'm getting out of it
the uh
the the funny thing is if is if you
juxtapose it to what McCarthy has said
or the GOP agenda is after midterm
elections do you know what it is what is
it entitlement reform
yeah so you have this guy screaming that
you know like they're going to genocide
your kids and then McCarthy's like
actually we just want to cut Social
Security
but it's just but on the other how do I
say this um I wish the GOP was half as
radical
um as these people think it is because
the disappointing thing is is that the
GOP is not nearly prepared to actually
use the the Electoral windfall that it's
going to get uh for nothing it did by
the way I think people are voting
Republican understandably because the
Democrats are so insane but the GOP I
don't think is prepared to actually use
the Electoral gains it's going to get to
change the trajectory of the country in
a meaningful way Bill Maher's a great
example of what's wrong with the left
because you can see it when he says
things on his show about the woke left
and and the whiny Millennial and gen Z
babies and all that stuff it's like okay
he's he's clearly heard something yeah
but he's not actually Google it like
he's seen a video on Twitter yeah and
then said Heaven's me I'm not going to
research that so then he goes on MSNBC
and he's like these right Wingers are so
violent it's like bro there was an
Insurrection on on May 29th 2020 where
there were thousands of far left
extremists there's photos of DC with
fires raging it's an overhead head view
of DCC smoke everywhere they tore it on
the barricades at the White House they
set fire to Saint John's Church they
firebombed a guard post in on the White
House grounds and they injured 150 cops
529 worse than January 6th yep no that's
exactly right the president was forced
into a bunker but I'm glad that Bill
Maher will just kind of reflexively you
know do that because it reminds people
that like you you can't trust people
like Bill Maher I'm sorry like the their
tendency is always going to be to punch
right at the moment of decision and I
think that's good that people are
reminded of that because there was a
moment where you know there was that
that the segment that Bill Maher did I
think with with uh with Weiss about
covid and like it was Weiss basically
finally saying like well I'm not
comfortable with like masking things
like that right it's like the rest of us
are like already fed up with this and
but because Barry Weiss and Bill Maher
talk about it now it's fine right now we
can we can start saying like the masking
and the vaccines and all the regulations
were dumb and wrong so I think it's good
that Mar will still kind of misstep and
expose himself I want to share this
photo yeah that's right I just go I just
Google dcblm rights yeah there's there's
this uh view I guess it came from a
helicopter and you can see black smoke
Rising there's actually a wider shot it
shows black smoke rising in several
areas this doesn't happen to these
people like in their minds this never
happened no you ask them out but what
are you talking about I actually saw
leftist journalists have a big Twitter
Thread about how the BLM protests were
peaceful
fiery but mostly peaceful that's what uh
who said that MSNBC CNN CNN these
there's a journalist who said the reason
why we take Maga so seriously blah blah
is because although there were protests
during BLM they were peaceful and we
didn't understand that when we go out
I'm like are you talking about people
died they literally got killed several
dozen yes people were killed billions of
dollars in damage yeah and then and then
you see you see that MSNBC thing where
they had the panel of trump supporters
and the house goes a cop died on January
6th and they're like no he didn't yeah
no he died later from natural
shot yeah that was the only that was the
only person who died as a direct result
of that of that whole thing let him keep
saying it you know why because
if there's anything you can do like you
know Ian you brought this up with your
mom when you said Biden shouldn't be
sniffing kids and she said he's not
doing that and then you showed her and
she went okay he shouldn't be doing that
if you can show someone not as an
adversary like here's a video of them
ransacking uh probably you know burning
St John's Church here's a video of a man
in Dearborn Michigan saying I don't like
sexually explicit books in my kids
libraries then they watch Colbert and
Colbert goes that never happened that it
didn't happen we looked into it
now all of a sudden that that Normie
aunt or Uncle of yours is watching be
like I actually saw that I saw that
video Colbert's lying Yep this is the
part in the movie where people start
pulling other people out of the Matrix
and start waking them up and if it's
because they're emotionally on the same
level it was like with the the whole uh
replacement Theory thing that happened a
while ago I wrote an article on Newsweek
um and it was just so easy to show that
the Democratic party has for decades
made it an official electoral strategy
to Simply replace the electorate like
it's it's they say it openly you know
like that basically fewer white people
means more wins for us like this is this
is not me saying this this is the
Democratic party saying it's and this is
why it fell apart was because it's like
no no we can just quote the New York
Times saying this but when Tucker
Carlson said this is what they're saying
they said he's promoting great
replacement that's right and it's like
he's quoting Democrats yes it's like
right the New York Times is promoting
the great replacement Charles blow you
know like the it's it's Democrat
politicians who are promoting it Tucker
is just repeating what you're saying in
your own words so no you're right like
the
do you allow these people to just show
you who they really are yeah but you're
not celebrating and cheering it on so
he's he's man bad but I do think the the
white angle is the incorrect angle like
I really don't care if a bunch of uh
Venezuelans come to the United States
for the most part because they hate
Communists like that's the reason
they're fleeing so typically when you
see like in my in Miami you'll meet
Venezuelans and Cubans they're like
communism is trash we love America this
is a great country Free Speech free
enterprise and I'm like I liked it these
are these are good people so it's not
it's not about race it's about values
the problem we have is they're bringing
in people who are just looking for an
economic opportunity and it's not it's
nothing to do with any of this when you
see people coming across the border it's
like I can make more money here they
don't know our values they don't believe
in our values and that's an issue for us
because Democrats are trying to bring in
people to to allow them to get political
power either through the census or
through creating new demographics new
voter bases but they're creating a
demographic of people who are like just
want something
so then you get voters who are like
don't care don't know if you give me
something I'll vote for you that's why
Joe Biden's like I'll give you 10 grand
towards your student loans I think I
mean there's there's a whole argument to
make that you know that the the identity
aspect does matter but from my position
I just think it's ghoulish to to
basically celebrate uh and Advocate
replacing the core demographic of a
country when has it ever happened before
when is it when has it been openly
discussed in human history like let's
take the the you know like the stock
population and just replace them yeah
it's not like I think the Romans for
sure but they don't talk jointly about
themselves I'm saying like that that's
just this has never happened before it
never in human history as a society uh
talked about its own core demographic
population like that like the Romans
didn't say we're going to replace
ourselves or something like that no no
they would replace the conquered Gauls
with Romans I really don't think that
anything is I don't I don't think the
immutable identity thing matters when
Candace Owens comes out they say she's a
white supremacist I get that too it's
because there's yeah that's the point
like if if what look the white liberals
not in agree with whatever they say so
it works for them
any other group that agrees with they
say it works for them but it's it's not
about race they'll come out and claim
you know this this white person who is
engaging in racist activities isn't
racist if it's in favor of them
affirmative action for instance or
creating segregated libraries like they
they did that educational thing and I
can't remember where it's Seattle or
whatever Dearborn did this with POC and
non-poc digital cafes if it's a white
person doing that it's not racist if
it's a conservative person if it's a
conservative white person no matter what
you do it's racist but if you're a
conservative black person if you're
Larry Elder you're the black face of
white supremacy so what I see is they're
looking for a way to bring in people who
don't care about the American ideology
the American way of life that's all that
matters if you were born in America and
you're a Marxist and you hate America
you are welcome they're not going to
insult you they're not going to smear
you you're you're good you're golden
even if you're white if you're a black
conservative but you believe in American
values and Free Speech you're a white
supremacist
yeah or Uncle Tom yeah I mean yeah sure
I think I think there's a middle ground
there between people like me and people
like you I mean that basically
yeah it does seem to be a a policy of
the Democrats to simply try to replace
the demographics that they view as
Troublesome whether or not that that's
actually true uh well that is that's
what they Advocate yeah it's a it's a
correlation right this country in the
60s I think was like 90 some odd percent
white most of these people are you know
they're Christian they're meritocratic
they're anti-communist sure so the
easiest way to Target that demographic
is the surface level racial attack
exploit racial animosity I mean I think
this is part of like the Communist
strategy for subverting a country but
the reality is you can be of any
background and have values that we think
are good and the Democrats will try to
destroy you they'll lie about you
they'll smear you and they don't want
you here yeah I think ultimately what
we're talking about is assimilation and
I think that
what we're saying is that people that
come to this country are expected to
assimilate into certain values right and
my position is just that the things that
we refer to as American values uh
originate in a specific demographic and
that's not to say that other people
can't you know assimilate into that uh
but assimilation is very tricky it
requires pauses in Immigration it
requires a kind of a basic understanding
of like house rules we don't have that
you know anything goes except of course
the things that we can characterize as
racist so yeah I mean I think there's a
there's an agreement there thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time